so we've been really very surprised by
the number of people that have watched a
video in the first five or six weeks
whoa shad pretty hard when I did the
introduction which some of you might
have already looked at I had no idea
what was going to happen and it was
really fun because just going through
the elements it was like visiting old
friends and we discovered new things
which we'd never really realized before
it's really quite fantastic as you could
hear too liquidy the Italian chemist
Finland lady so it's just about cool now
this the ball of copper copper metal but
this video their website we know had
nearly one and a half million people but
it's not just that they've been watching
it but we've got really quite a lot of
the feedback if you look here on that
one of these elements here that we've
had a whole series of comments from
people for example this has been a
comment on the element and then opium
the very last one 118 which else does
when we wouldn't do a few molecules as
well
co2 DNA exciting molecules and this is
really made us think that we we need to
update them all of the website keep it
instead of a just a dead object
something that is live and is going to
develop from one week to the next
so you can see the nose
yeah so you can see it's kind of shiny
by there it quickly forms a layer of
some of oxides and nitrides in the ends
so Brady is working with me and my
colleagues each week to try and give you
a new element either just because we've
thought of a nice experiment which we
haven't done before or we found a nice
sample or because something exciting has
happened in the news which makes it
really important you should start
thinking about these new elements the
phosphorus itself is in our bodies as
phosphate lots and lots of it too it's
very very common in Navarre okay not see
if it in yellow which is the organic bit
going as well I think that it really is
quite important to us to hear from the
people that we are talking to and I've
realized that I've lectured in the past
five weeks to more people than the whole
of the rest of my life in fact in one
night I think more people watch the
videos than I've ever lectured to in my
life and we want to know what you all
think we can't obviously respond to all
of you but we will try and answer your
comments so if you post them on our
website or on YouTube and we're looking
at blogs and so on for example there's a
blog over here if you look this is a
Russian blog and in which they made some
quite interesting suggestions down here
and we've tried to look at these we've
found websites in Turkish in Hungarian
one of my students translated the
Hungarian website for me and we're
trying to listen to what people say
because our aim is to tell you about why
we think chemistry is exciting and why
we want you to feel that it's exciting
to